μου είχε πει στέλα νομίζω θα είναι δύσκολο και νομίζουμε έχαμε μαζευτίκο σπέντι γυναίκες απολιτική
πρόμος κάθε χρονο συγκινούμε συγκινούμε όχι για τις ίδιες τις γυναίκες μόνο αλλά το ότι
έρχεται ο καθένας οποίος κάθεται σπίτι του αντι να βλεπει τη λεόραση βάζια να ρώσιον
κάκι στο σκύλο του στο κατετσάκι μετο μορών του και έρχεται να περπατήσει για ένα
κοινόσκοπό έχουμε ανάγκη ως κοινωνία σε μια εποχή που τα πάντα τα παξιώνουμε υπάρχει μια
το ξηκότητα είμαστε κεί όλοι μαζί για ένα κοινό σκοπό και νωμίζω για αυτό έρχεται
ο κόσμος ότι εγώ πάντα έχω αυτό το ρεδματικό χιλιάδες κάθε χρόνο νομίζομα σενόνι ανάγκη
που έχει ο άνθρωπος ότι είναι εκεί για ένα κοινό σκοπο σας ενόχλησε ποτε εστο
και ισκέψει γιατί πολλές φορές υπόθηκε αυτό ότι σως κάποιοι να εκμεταλλεύονται αυτή την μπορεία
γιαδικό τους όφελος να εφανίζονται και για δικών τους οφέλως ένα πράγμα το οποίο γίνεται
για άλλον σκοπο όχι τε με ενόχλησε μποτε ούτε με προβληματίζει νομίζω ότι ο καθένας
που είναι εκει οι άρχεται για ένα δικών του λόγο δε δε με προβληματίζει αυτό
αλλά ξέρετε πήγα πίσω σε κάτι μου είπατε πγαίνοντας πίσω και λίγο στη θητία μου
και με ρωτή ατι για στιγμές με τη γυρόπατων χαμία στιγμή στη θεητία μου που
δεν έχει σχέση με τη γύρο αφατό αλλα έχει σχέσι σε όσε σόσα κράτι με
λυπήγαινα επισκεφτόμου να πάντα και ογκολογικά νοσοκμ και ο λόγος ήταν δι ότι δεν πιστεύω
ότι μπορείς να εφαρμόζεις μια πολιτική γνωρίζοντας μόνο των υπουργό ηγίαση σα ένα γραφείο σ
ένα υπουργείο να συζητά χορίς να τις μετα μάτιας ου να πας μετα μάτιας στου
να περπατήσει στων νοσοκομείου κ όταν πηγαίνω στα νοσοκομία περνού παίρνουμε